we've seen five years of falling living  standards five years of an NHS going  backwards five years of broken promises  they think that is all a great success  imagine what they think failure looks  like sometimes I feel like a firefighter  there's EDD Miliband coming round day  off today the man who set the fire there  in the first place complaining we're not  putting it out fast enough you'll never  get a turn with you don't know yet  French culture I mean the praise do  support you so I guess we have achieved  after a million conversation I'm saying  us a new target which is to have another  million Dorset conversation in the next  week can we achieve that come on a bit  louder better sons are people with a fit  for editorial policy in Scotland a  welcome their support your own past  thank you for food in from Scotland and  doing it for the women